[Music]
[Applause]
17 years
the marlins are going to the postseason
congrats marlins and mattingly it is the
final weekend of the major league
baseball's regular season one that was
cut short
and played without fans because of the
coronavirus pandemic
well mostly without fans as brook silva
braga found out there's a small
group of so-called fandemics out there
who go to great heights
just for a glimpse of the game getting
the ladders out
it can be hard at first to understand
another person's passion
it's a lot of ladders sure is when major
league baseball announced they'd play
without
fans brett mcmahon and oscar alvarado
had other ideas we were like what's
keeping us from
coming to see our guys behind this fence
did you know you'd be able to see them
not in the beginning the secret they
soon learned that one's yours
yeah the green one's mine was in their
garage did you
get a little higher there are some
flagpoles though that are you got some
flag poles on the way
four feet up a ladder way behind the
center field fence of citizens bank park
they found baseball you got the pitcher
you can see the both dugouts
and okay wanna drive to right it looks
like
over the summer the little group grew
and took a name
the fandemic crew their goal was
not only to see who knew i'd be an
airhorn expert
but to be heard
that worked out too in august yankee
manager aaron boone complained the air
horns were distracting his batters
we just kind of policed ourselves out
here and saying hey
next time when uh opposing batters come
up let's let's let them do their thing
more quietly other fans around the
country have found ways to watch
there's a strike bottom outside corner
strike
ken holliday's apartment building boasts
an amenity he couldn't pass
up a sight line onto washington
nationals park
how much of a factor was that view that
was the factor
i looked around the building and it was
it was okay it was nice they took me up
to the roof
i saw that field and i was like where do
i sign
in chicago the famous wrigley rooftops
reopened
even from there mike mitchell managed to
get the players attention
i'm getting wrigley field it's the best
place in the world it's the cathedral of
chicago
but in this strange season few people
were more motivated to find a view
than ryan hart he knew i was gonna do
whatever it took to get there
when his kid brother kyle got called up
by the red sox to make his major league
pitching debut
ryan rushed from memphis to boston and
secured a table at the bleacher bar
this was kyle warming up his proud
brother just a
mesh fence and garage door away from
fenway park
if you didn't know it was your brother
on the mound would you have been able to
say
that's him i've got really good eyesight
i don't know that you could discern
you might be able to recognize the
number 81 the experience is different
than it would be in a normal year
but you know if anything maybe it makes
it a little bit more memorable
there's always been something romantic
about sneaking a peek at baseball
my father took me up through the ladder
in the skylight and he said here's
something
jack that you can remember all your life
jack
rooney's rooftop offered a one-of-a-kind
view it overlooked shibe park
home of the philadelphia athletics
during their heyday
in the late 1920s lou gehrig hit wanda
right through the transom above the door
the window that's right above the door
that little window above the door
to the team's dismay those 20th street
roofs
offered a better view than some seats in
the stadium
i said you want to see the game for a
quarter and i pointed up to the rooftops
and
a couple of men there they looked up and
they said yeah let's go
rooney is 97 now the park is long gone
but his memoir bleachers in the bedroom
recalls a time when even the stadium
across the street
didn't always lock its doors the door to
the player's locker room was open
some of the kids came in there they saw
the yankees
uniforms they were the visiting team
then and so
they brought them out one two took them
out of the stadium
out of the street right here onto the
street to a near wall to a nearby park
and they put on the
suits and start you know they're hanging
on them start to play
baseball pretending they were the new
york yankees
wearing babe ruth's real jersey that's
right
but the romance on 20th street ended
bitterly
in 1935 the athletics got tired of the
competition
and built a fence to block the view in
2004 the cubs owners threatened
something similar at wrigley
but instead bought up the rooftops
themselves
and this year charged 400 a ticket
people just want to see baseball man
they want to see sports they want to be
out here
the only cost to watch the phillies on
10th street was a requirement to wear a
mask
and keep your distance
[Music]
though in the end the only explanation
for their passion
was a desire to be together we're season
ticket holders here
and we do miss uh sitting next to the
people that
watch so many games with for the for
years and watch their kids grow up
and we're missing all of that right now
just being next to our friends and
family
that's that's what we miss for cbs this
morning saturday brook silva bracka
on a ladder in philadelphia